This mission is a simple in and out.
Agent Valerian, you'll be running solo.
I only work with my partner. We're a team.
Let's go!
You are running nearly twenty minutes late.
Yeah, well time flies when you are having fun.
Welcome to Alpha.
The city of a thousand planets.
where for hundreds of years,
every species has shared their knowledge.
and their intelligence
with each other.
It's paradise
Amazing
After centuries of peace and prosperity
an unknown force wants to destroy all we have created
Agents Valerian and Laureline, you have less than 10 hours to find the threat and eliminate it
The whole universe is after us
We need the two of you to be the guardians of our future
You sure you know what you are doing?
Valerian, trust me
How much time left?
I taught him how to do that